[music]
thank you for training and you can't
wait to work shop and what
the founder of
workshops from the waikato interpol
my name is angelica member of life
science topics attract attention that my topic
for high tech Gründerfonds one to three
college frank lewis and katharina
philippi how awesome insights into fine
in kampen die haut ab immediate
and
company
angelika voß and production to a
happy to review the introduction to say
die cfs angelika people time of my
life science team so biology spread to
patients for myself between were 2000
must win 2015  centerstage deg fans brought
into detailon company said its
business talk ag
prcenter.de f what little bit more do
you know focus and life science
drug development area who will be in the focus of
button general ad de france tick funds
and investinlife that we in the
westin technology and of  technology
interdisciplinary team of people for all
kaindorf success a double
josef was founded in 2005 es public
private p  artnership cep time
this image of the money coming from you
ministry of economy
stupid german government
to
basics private companies like
basf bosch and siemens for example
is very important to
make sure that of corporate counsel
into the
startups.de beer pur last financial
investor des  hacker forums decides
july slate
gray matter is the
motor company said files
permanent presence of the man i came from the
government mond if
from
german corporate like
bayer basf again for example better than
but on site sautorn
venture capital works house sees
investment burg center
support the german  star of culture
2007 the race touareg 3 found many more
investor service in the city
company
spending in
berlin
possibly
winslet
fenty million
yes we can send to invest interest of
companies
the tcf seven investment face off
fixed
who actively investing in houston it is
just event period  since
we follow investment paper from the
second exit from the investment  trade
sales at
how focus on stage as well as the find stage of
this new company
cell essence we should let out in
2011 out of the air massively
and wii invested estate normally
6000 subway lines eurocents
registry million investment company
boston
usa sa investor
what do you to value
operations
deals
here with
answers
from
[music]
investment
and compete with
network of corporate business angels
june
2011 to
rawlinson banana deals like luck den
tumor play to the legends and became
a bit more
605 the startup company as well as invested
den
[music]
reservists important
driver  .foto venture capital move into the
in germany the
[music]
importance of external money-management
intro portfolio companies
modest up to more than three point 6
billion us- bridges what
[music]
invested bye bye bye corporates at
how many
portfolio is
here  it first liquidity merkel 64
in greece and insecurity
606 to the media
sven den tumor
in into a company th  at
little please dilemma on of the german
venture market 6 5 million dancers
to act high mount gay of germanwings
treats the media from the front how
relieves
you anyway what are you so big sid
marketing the german venture capital
market how to videos it
is great so support  and network like give
the support company 2
events like family day will be the
family so startups
venture capital funds about sensors
again a family day
you are the event in
bonn half high-tech partnering
conference which is why
like connector company is corporate voice
over ip
stack  before interactions to promote
interactions between the company or
companies that
matter private investor circle like connect
startup company spacey volunteers
because they individually
trade tickets on a tour like
trade 1000
euros' synthies company half the chain
patch day for example life science
patchday
patch day of berlin  based company
spac patchdays would not have large network
resource wi  rd as enemy of the deals is
an example from the life science
area and he wants connected to a
business plan contest jury of several
business plan contest Serbian very
early on
the water
technologies we participating
individuation due to program leaks
is unique you in the foreword for example of
global and we have  klaus connection to
the national and international
security something like this start agreement interesting
company comes up
close and
expect that each day we try to bring
together everybody from see venture
capital see him in the euroeyes the
reputable times
will often have a folder events connectu
and of  course we know the
example
of
development company
hurley so 1000 sorts finished 610
relatively small sees investment cfds
want to have fun for example boehringer
ingelheim manager found wellington
partners this company 2 brown
interested parties able to
access the legends of investments
this sees brown
2016  is harms puts more money on the
market  and
the brown scott lago so
round of ten media plastik sets
can and lee
commented on the status quo morles
what you can trust drug development
company early stage and you can't
really decide for yourself sing for crm valentes
very good christ six seven million swiss
trinks respect  opposition
in
germany the
way you want him from the
participating mouse on the
financing 1
this is an overview of life science
portfolio
viewers we've never been
investing in drug development
of numbers as it is in terms of
mind of financing patriots invest the
tools new  materials for example
neuromodulation
digital hands of core switches very much
coming up
your life science portfolio is
half of all tort teams techteam start in
the software as a service team
portfolios
in
morelia by lewis on the built in
island want to access the
company
to get money as  well as the example of the
[music]
of drug development much so very nice
exit let you
mu  sical soul for two one point for being
used to be at
investment and investments du
[music]
developer hepatitis the
treatment of
market approval in tenero sport bye bye
billag
motto we never have it
no the professional swissness
backgrounds
page the sea life science in avid
technology
with more than three trading now
on experience investment area hv team
ass.tec background hafencity failure traffic
light have experience and experience sv
and den vfb bot experience covering old
technology from quantum computers
working in
indifference institutes
as well as
have any questions happy to answer
ds inside are that  sees
everything state the auditorium be happy to
that never
catch and
how to get
what
kind of information correctly im
interested in the
deep end
data
base of
sony tubing is a stewardess
discuss the investor how to investor
how to commercial technology
[music]
you  need you need fantasy nadia
joppen des tutors theater company flur
the perfect and complete team to
expect estate finance limited
complete team can be built up so if
you're the scientific preview of prey 2
1 is also find ich very okay
university
of science in winzingen to get you gotta
des investors and you get around  5
million hefte manitu
[music]
to get the missing expert
franz xaver
difference a lot of expertise
expertise is need to develop it
for the winner petra
clinics expertise skan camps later than
you need to be connected the haspa is
internally trust company still to
start
johanna
[Music]
getting the
progress software
expert
macxperts will not be a hero
everywhere consulting marketing expert to the
company
challenge wisse company wandlitz
you never know
discussing the sea company autopsy
start how dumont
investor coming on invest as an expert
switcher tickets discover owned
island company
report for you  speak now the
company is for example
company
investor skating die port expert  e
thinks your body squeezing from digital
ok thank you frank
michael lewis
holby overview of canada stakes
gets on financing
very important persons
who are actually king of the franks top
25 combat oath pictures one two go
dancing going to get to the stage
company is actually vanderbilt
bavaria in westerbeck by thomas 11 louis a
software investment team so bit of the
different no of investing to be honest
junior teams closer to the market
perspectives
[music]
the
motivation of
5.6 then because look that before
fundraising now basically will
prevail here if  your look and changes
tinga diaz if your talk to what i
waited women this because here is the word
against the penguins
0 research company structure and health
setup am then both company than
you find out at the murders of stage
standard interview investment should
n't be weathered  11 motivation to
everyone to start in company to think
about this topic therefore word actions to
take for  possible to get venture
financing of
china is financed most active
sees investor jörg butt
success factor the festival in wetzlar the
jump interest must come is ex nfl
franz because they want the feeling most
of the trouble touring financing is built on
topic
justine otto traun
scotland  location of the complete ran a
fair good idea and what you want to you
knew i recently meanwhile often leads
youtube stream more often that they just
get back and thinking about ok
verdasco money actually i got over is
so much money is offered by the tennis club
education der  discuss the founders and
just my remarks very difficult to go to
investors days 15 million
comeback when you slater say okay the uk
plate is one million becomes a computer
enemy of a thousand user works and
first knows if before it did the fundraising
yes double check out of  money june
david checks investments relations
letter outdoor & market like cause of
course i travel agent one step up t  o the
press how precious outstanding is not
every day visit companies in the
software industry race 2 5 million us-
set exceptions to just a check the
funding strategy before now lie under
fundraising
second that something with more often
lag
trent university college
teams exchange
the
contractor very
help when take care of topix like what
happens the dearest company on
investment the düffel possibility siegl
how to get that it's pretty car that
continues driving the company after one
person with the stars the first person
that left for example which we like des
system veins in  the company also
user the ssv team of very good friends
that were to have to
early and other people have to come in
and dance very important that i have
taken kehrli galli & company setup so
costs of money but it's worth a
contract with the
next
stage  of the
current launched more often that when we
look im stage im interview holte
structure the tree
state of equity give  n the way to the
success of corporate it could have been
given the way to software developer kit
and how money but i
can't wait to
say okay in the west the industry with
contracts partie africa equity fonds
receives fundraising partie is fierce me
equity
fonds  growth created with
business angels the cs ok
think
equity is
betty
white
end up will not come up if the
shareholder structure wanted something
that is huge problem in front of institutional
investors the cause our ideas to
investment company who mainly the
oberliga team and operations team should
have the
outstanding gravel  loaded
steak in known event the
investigator present because the shower
over the next financing of the world but
if you ready steady
state no off cap table dance night run
into incentive concentration
problem certain this and that does nothing we
can investor now
possible to hear what it is  very
difficult
to have the people stressed
business angel ok
weig  ht of holding into the chair option
program
ends on very hard conversations as well as
maine massachusetts
in the beginning is have company
limited resource and easy to pay as you
think about it
right
way too much
intellectual property that something
that works is from the team total chaos like
it  with lot of research institutions from the
university salt company spin out there
you shall i tv and the issue develop art
on stage in the play-off research
institute of world universities and then
it's not always close to the actual
intellectual property balance in the end
and what  is important for assist
investor is the tui in west end to
weeks truck the way we think that you
need to be successful is part of the
company
at least is exclusively usable
at is a could competitive edge to
invest in the technology the west is
nothing  that can be used by any other
competitors because it is known so here
is a jude company of the start of the
company men spin out of univ
ersities much easier to talk about
it belongs how transfer company a
morelli stage before the lot of money and
wolff as well as calls for financing around and
racing
much as i can say we need to say we
need to develop my project is
my song that's something to take  care
of
and now the last big
point in the software knowledge is the
feeling like the start of the company
what starts him but if a diabetic
cargo on fundraising then over it next
finance inga and next club internal
exit
fc
affing is in the plate needed always
you need  venture capital of course of
you obedient frank set develop
technology development rugby costs
chains rewe news from the market as well as
all i can get papi cranes i can get
funding to keep your company going the
lot of business models from the user
food bank research of services in the
die you can also
and scale of it out venture capital and
lots of the model that which usually
junot investment last important to
understand now not just to race
venture capital now possibility of
service cable business model to do so
and of course especially with the
product will where you have to heaven
lot of investments done before you can
actually go to market news and scale
junior resources and promote full  and
finance customer last message
the double click the company is kept
alot of what it's not that is just like
physical yourself a new safe than you
can but
that's it already had once contact die
tales my portfolio
and as always happy to answer questions
and think we  hear the world of the times
el fandi specific topic you can also per
liter
henkel is big nonsense
yes we can talk about some company
takes place and that on open source
software
a
software package
a replaceable startup company
throws the software
excellent
service
verification
dementi is open  source
developers can build with something the
extent of product that
something we are open
source company that gets funding the
helper on the technology
nike ipod protected skin picture business
model
that light offers case which
demonstration much later the building up
community making sure the computer to
the open source software motives
[music]
in the picture doctors community
you need to date
in the open source industry
trying to convince the action user of my
software
developer tools software costs leaves
then computing software only saw it for
small project is like working
environment ace in working environment
and to more details of features comes with
open source software commercial  usable
bachelor open source business models
work will come a developer index
company sobeida with a developing a
no speech recognition
tools
open source software works very well we
should be alive the mix from gypsum as an
opportunity to use it commercial and to
get developers to use  software community
building aspect is very important
endless models are
usually  the set up period value loves
community before you can't start a
rwe fans on your product will be the
functional thies here we come again
commercial expect to denmark
west schneider
louis talk the short of night
with a very
multiple
shareholders what you see is so good
mood message to gain network
campaigns at the moment
one can den does not have enough man so
maxian stewart and difficult to execute
the very good teams
with zdf because they can say there
because of the motive aging everything of the
blankets on board advisory becomes palin one
him just because  and wise is the
last team but under support dad says
it will move pharmaceutical industry forward to
be part of it all want to support a
late-night
get some like monster incentives not
starting point values
ry help you start will so albert be ve
y careful special stage
volks traffic light in the skin and contributed to the
software industry when a live event
receives wise process hail to the
fundraising for you s  omething that i
would never cry on bike from obediently
proves the checks fermenter
notes that state that very skeptical because you
look that you still fundraising
because it's usually tv that the tvi in
nside take that once you want to see t
e montecito fundraising convention assem
lies  customers will be the product
that we're very skeptical that's about
half and stage bernadette equity
rhythm
collections button it was with george whether
the cases albert because just look for
someone else's
henkel oeser things but well know
well
have never
programmed that
campos difficult but  after staying
grand prix for exercise books set the
target has 59 cents and hopefully as
often as text finance im
rasenviereck the panel of concept
reymond but if you're adefg 350 ps
and read the
waves of
just too much like what this have im
set
zero  point for one two centers of
what you can as a duo some times come to
me but we need that advice and monsters
because just  had a clear contract vw bosses
chain choirblax success have us as an
industry network can give you
introduction studios customers the devil
you bio customers the
customers and roll
but also link
will
thank you have to the question switch
came you have the post has been
[music  ]
mr important is mondello deep money
for the financing also
money from the grand so not afraid hat color
life science team lady q cells des
steffens in the software team special i
like throwing hardware / industrial
software team will it would be software products are
far away from the market  by a team of
cost investment needed to build a
product to get the blues but it's not
significant like in the hardware life
science industry as a
motive money is not the importance of
cosmetic
success ampelmann portfolio company
internal truth to check of bluetooth
programs and found what we  like more
details about the self and that's right but if
you stayed putting the foundation
schilling on phorms and lo
oking for monday with plans the muscle of the
emergency call dangers of time so
rhythm flow live talk to one
company that left on line on the loose
plans for the last two years
that they are not the hands on when it
comes to the market access
catalog of money  can develop new
products long time they do not have to
the test des online marketing of money
that cannot your child
software industry because it's possible
to go to go with it security products
just
like it is money is not the
like operation lag wie dich zu  the
company to
have to look
of
money
money in the option with tempo
found yes if ok oh you have to wait to
[music]
important israels tract dataroom a
mini together sunpoint intelligence
the betting sponsor
investor enyo interested in you and
your company is what  you are a lot
of very good evil structure dataroom
now your prepaid shows that you
know what investors with look for
what it's like
the jack casey d'elegance of the date  of
this truck is that would come back for
feedback haute structures
now whether it's wet
prepaid procedure the snowboard
doing all fundraising process
important butt the effect continued
in the morning that in the del point
and lewis but was fine from the
auditorium
the interest not so
we  have you
[music]